transaction management and finally we
will wind up the session by learning
spring aop terminology and configuration
and also don't miss the key takeaways
from this tutorial at the end i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
without any further ado let's get
started
let's start with spring mvc architecture
and components
the problems in enterprise application
development with servlet and jsp servlet
and code are not usable
web designing tools can't be used in
case of servlet parallel development is
not possible to solve the problems and
microsystems introduced two design
patterns for developing
enterprise applications model one paid
centric model and model to mvc
so here we have a request coming in
to the jsp page the request is forwarded
to the java bin so that the object can
be created
it connects to the
enterprise server or data source
and then the response is generated to
the browser
request is sent by browser and received
by jsp javabean object is created and
business methods are called if required
it communicates with the databases to
get the required data jsp then displays
the process data to the end user
there is no clear separation of
responsibility jsp access both
controller and view and the business
logic is separated using javabean
so now here you can see that the request
comes to the servlet which access the
controller
the servlet can
actually connect to the model java bin
which maps to the data source using some
orm like hibernate
that
content can directly be pushed into the
jsp as well in case there is no data
and it can then go to the model bin and
retrieve data from the database via the
jsp as well and finally the response is
sent to the browser
controller servlet receives request from
browser and captures the input
controller invokes the business method
of model or java bean model connects
with database and gets business data
model sends response to controller keeps
the process data in heap memory request
session and servlet context and
controllers which is the control to
appropriate view of the application
the limitations of the mvc model clear
separation of responsibility code
reusability single point entry for
application and support for multiple
view technologies
spring mvc is used to develop web
application that uses mvc design
patterns spring mvc is meant to make web
applications development faster cost
effective and flexible
contents of spring mvc we have the
dispatcher servlet we have the handler
mapping the controller
mode and view and view resolver
the dispatcher servlet it is given by
aux spring framework dot dispatcher
servlet it controls the front controller
design pattern
and whatever url comes from client
servlet intercepts the client request
before passing the request object to
controller in the web config file write
servlet mapping in such a way that
dispatcher servlet is invoked for client
request
then we have the handler mapping it is
an interface implemented by objects to
define mapping between request and
handler objects when a request is made
to springs dispatcher servlet it hands
over the request to handler mapping
handler mapping inspects the request
identifies the appropriate handler
execution chain and it delivers it to
dispatcher servlet
handle mapping provided by spring mvc
module can be implemented in many ways
bean name url handler mapping which is
the default handler mapping class that
maps the url request to the name of the
beans
if url pattern welcome dot htm is
requested dispatcher servlet will
forward the request to welcomecontroller
if streetname.htm is requested it will
forward the request to street name
controller and if processcredit.htm is
requested it will forward the request to
processcontroller
the controller are components that are
called by dispatcher servlet for any
kind of business logic all controllers
implement controller interface the types
of controllers are abstract multi-action
and abstract wizard form
there are components called view
resolver their job is to provide mapping
between logical view name and actual
physical location of the view resource
then we have the model and view it is
represented by class
awk.stringframework.web.servletmodelnview
and is returned by the controller object
back to the dispatcher servlet
this class is just a container class for
holding the model in the view
information the model object represents
some piece of information that can be
used by the view to display the
information this gives abstraction in
the spring framework any kind of view
technology can be plugged into the
framework like excel jasper reports pdf
xslt free marker html tiles are
supported frameworks
then we have the view resolver it is an
interface implemented by objects to
resolve views using name spring mvc's
module it encapsulates the module view
and the view object in a single entity
which is represented by the object of
class model and view to resolve the view
object dispatcher servlet view resolver
is used
internal resource views resolver it
resolves the logical name of the view to
an internal resource by free fixing the
logical view name with the resource path
and suffixing it with the extension it
resolves the logical name of the view to
the beam name which will render the
output to the user the beam should be
defined in spring app context file this
view resolver is the same as being name
view resolver the only difference is
that instead of looking for the beams
and springs application context file it
looks for beans defined in a separate
xml file
spring mvc framework
the spring mvc web framework provides
model view controller architecture that
can be used to develop flexible and
loosely coupled web apps
so here we see the steps the request
comes to the servlet dispatcher it goes
to the handler mapping
the handler mapping sends
back to the respect dispatcher servlet
that access the controller we then call
the handlerequest method on the
controller
which calls the business methods on the
service
which in turn calls the davo method
which talks to the database and gets the
response the response is sent to the
service
sent back to the controller
sent back to the
servlet dispatcher which forwards it to
the view resolver so the right view can
be returned to the servlet dispatcher
the servlet dispatcher then picks up the
model attaches it to the view and
generates the response so client
requests a resource in the web
application the spring front controller
dispatches servlet request the handler
mapping to identify the particular
control of a given url handler mapping
identifies the controller and sends it
to the dispatcher servlet dispatch a
servlet calls handle request method and
passes these two objects to the
controller
controller calls the business method
service class calls the davo method for
business data dao interacts with the
database to get the data database shares
the result dao returns this result data
to service dow data is processed
according to business requirement and
returns to controller controller returns
model and view object back to font
controller
dispatcher resolves actual view by
consulting the view resolver object
view resolver renders view to the
dispatcher dispatcher servlet consults
the view to the dispatcher servlet
view executes and returns html to the
dispatcher servlet dispatches servlet
sends output to the browser
the request processing workflow of
spring web mvc dispatcher subreddit is
illustrated in the following diagram
the handler mapping
going to the dispatcher servlet second
is the controller
data exchange
with the dispatcher servlet then it
communicates with the view resolver
and finally the view and the response is
sent
out after receiving an http request
dispatcher servlet consults the handler
mapping to call the appropriate
controller the controller takes the
request and calls the appropriate
service method based on used get or post
method the service method will set model
data based on defined business logic and
return view name to the dispatcher
servlet the dispatcher servlet will take
help from view resolver to pick up the
defined view for the request once view
is finalized the dispatcher servlet
passes the model data to the view that
is finally rendered on the
browser configurations required for
spring mvc map requests that you want
the dispatcher server to handle using
url mapping in web xml create servlet
name servlet xml file define a
controller create a view
so you map requests that you want the
dispatcher servlet to handle by using
url mapping in web xml file use the
following code declare the map hello web
dispatcher servlet the web.xml file will
be kept in webinf directory
then you create the servlet.xml file
framework will try to load the
application context from a file name
servlet xml located in the application's
web content directory
the file name is helloweb.xml
the servlet name xml file will be used
to create the defined beans overwrite
the definitions of beans with the same
name in the global scope
the component scan tag will be used to
activate string mvc annotation scanning
capability which allows you to make use
of annotations like controller and
request mapping and the internal
resource viewer resolver will have rules
defined to resolve the view names
we define a controller the actuate
controller annotation indicates that a
particular class serves the role of a
controller the at the rate request
mapping annotation is used to map a url
to either an entire class or a
particular handler method the request
mapping method is used to declare the
print hello method as the controller's
default service method to handle http
get requests
then we create a view spring mvc
supports many types of views for
different presentation technologies
these include jsp html pdf excel
worksheet xml velocity template xslt
json view in webinar choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to
1000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more finally the spring mvc program
let's write a simple web-based
application using spring mvc to create a
spring mvc model to display hello world
so the request will come in here saying
hello dot jsp we will use at the right
request mapping then the dispatcher
servlet will communicate with the hello
controller then the internal resolver
view resolver and finally the hello dot
jsp which will generate the response the
hello world example uses spring web mvc
framework to follow the model view
controller architecture the controller
is responsible for processing user
requests and building an appropriate
model it then passes the model to the
view for rendering in this example hello
controller java class is controller the
view is responsible for rendering the
model data in general it generates html
output that the client's browser can
interpret in this example hello.jsp is
the view
we create a dynamic web project with the
name hello web we then add jr file to
web content webinaf lib then we create a
java class hello controller and the src
folder then we create spring
configuration file web xml and hello
servlet under the web content inf folder
then we create a subfolder with the name
jsp under web content then we create a
view file hello jsp under the subfolder
the final step is to create the content
of all the source and config files and
export the application
here are the steps we create a dynamic
web project that we have already learnt
we add the following jars servlet api
common logging spring aop spring beans
spring context spring core spring
expression spring web mvc and spring web
then we write the atterrate controller
in request mapping to slash hello we
write the controller with the request
method as get and we say model dot add
attribute message hello spring framework
then we create the spring config file
that maps the dispatcher servlet object
and the hello web
then we map the spring framework
internal resource view resolver as well
and we put the
web inf jsp property
mapped to that particular folder path
then we create the subfolder with a view
hello dot jsp which simply returns hello
world and dollar of messages the
expression
to run the application we say
localhost port helloweb and hello
we'll write a simple web-based
application that makes use of html form
using spring mvc framework to submit the
data to the controller and display a
process result
so the moment we say project name slash
employee it will go to the dispatch
dispatcher servlet which will talk to
the employee controller retrieve the
employee object
move to the internal resource review
resolver which picks up the
result.jspnemploy.jsp views and send it
out as a http response
mvc architecture for form handling
example the form handling example uses
spring mvc framework it follows model
view control architecture the model
encapsulates the application data and
consists of pojo it creates employee
class containing id name and age the
controller is responsible for processing
user request building an appropriate
model and passes it to the view for
rendering it creates an employee
controller.java class to call employee
class methods the view is responsible
for rendering the model data and in
general it generates html output that
the client browser can interpret
java.jsp files result.jsp in
employee.jsp are used to display
employees information
steps to write a web-based application
using spring mvc we create a dynamic web
project and add the required jar files
we then map the request that you want
the dispatcher servlet to handle by
using url mapping in web xml you then
create the java class employee you then
create employee controller in src folder
you then create spring config web xml
and servlet xml under web contact web
inf you then create a sub folder with
the name jsp under web contact inf you
then create view file employee.jsp
you then create second view file
result.jsp and the final step is to
create the content of all the source and
config files and export the application
now we create a dynamic web project and
add the required jar files common
logging aux spring framework asm aux
spring framework beam aux spring
framework context aux spring framework
core expression web servlet web and
spring web dot jar
we then define the spring web
configuration file web.xml where we set
up the dispatcher servlet we give the
servlet name as helloweb
we then set up the employee class with
age name and id
we then create the controller with a
request mapping of a url employee and
mapped to a request dot get method
we then return model and view with the
employee and command and the new
employee object we then do another
mapping for the request method dot post
this is from the form data to be posted
we provide the add employee method and
add attribute mappings for name agent id
next we create a spring config file web
xml and servlet xml
which map the jsp page
then we create a subfolder in a view
which maps the
view information
as a employee.jsp file where we create a
simple table to print out the data
we create a second view called
result.jsp which has a separate table
that this gives us the name age and id
of the employee
we create content for all the source and
config files and we run the application
let's look at a demo on spring web mvc
let's start with a small demo
demonstrating the capability
of spring web mvc
so let's move to eclipse
so spring mvc
is an end-to-end solution for complete
web app development
the servlet plays the role of the
controller and jsp plays the role of the
view
it follows the fun controller design
pattern this means there will be a
servlet is a controller and the model
caters to collecting the data
there is complete sync between the model
the view is handled by
the controller which is a form of mvc
design pattern
so spring mvc
has a front controller which is the
dispatcher servlet
so we have created a dynamic web project
and we have added the libraries
so the reference libraries are all the
spring libraries in addition to that we
have added
the commons
logging
which is the
other important library that we have
added
we have a views folder that has four
views home profile register trainee and
success
let's look at
the web.xml file
here we have the dispatcher servlet
configured with the name as myservlet
and here we are configuring myservlet
with a url pattern of slash indicating
that any
request that comes to the dispatcher
servlet which acts as a controller
will be catered to by the dispatcher
servlet so the moment you put a slash
which is the root url
in the address bar the request will come
and hit the dispatcher servlet
then we have the
myservlet-servlet.xml file
so here we can actually see
that the sprig web container is going to
look for this file
it is going to look for jsp pages inside
this path which is web inf views and
that is where we have stored our jsp
pages
it will search for the controllers in
the com.controllers package
and here in the source in the
com.controllers package we have set up a
controllers as you can see here
the internal resource view resolver will
find out which particular jsp page is to
be returned
so the prefix is the part where
the jsp
are stored and the suffix is it's going
to post fix all the view names with a
dot jsp extension
next we come to the
my controller
dot java file
we use the annotation controller we are
mapping to the root so if somebody gives
the url the end user passes the url as a
slash
we are going to print home in the
console and simply return
the home dot jsp page so the suffix will
be appended to this
we have another function
called say name
so in case
we request for this particular url route
we will get the first name parameter
from a form
we will map the attribute
of this particular value first name
and we will return the profile view
which is again present in the views
folder as we see here
we have a third route set up for the url
login so if the url is slash login we
will track the username and password
fields from the form
we will check if the username and
password equals tom and jerry we will
add the attribute
and we will return the profile page
if there is an error we will simply
return an error message
so that constitutes
the mycontroller
let's look at the home.jsp
we have the same name
action method which will post to the say
name
request map that we saw in the
controller the method is post we have a
submit button with fname
and we have a login controller with
username and password and a submit
button and this is mapping to the action
method login and those are the two
action methods we saw we are mapping to
say name or login
we'll come to the home
page
and we'll execute this
we'll go to the default route which is
just a slash which takes us to the home
page
and here
it simply gives us a welcome message as
of now which says hello
welcome to spring
which we see
is the default
welcome message that we are actually
getting
and we also have a say name function
that is actually getting mapped when we
click on this button
and we are going to route
to a success page so here
let's print
first name
and we can see here
that we are actually going to map to the
first name function and if we go to the
controller
we have created an attribute first name
to which we are mapping this value
okay and we are
simply returning
the user information so in case
there is a success it will simply go
ahead
and route to that particular
url so we'll just provide
or rather let's me go here
rather than the success and we'll make
that change so we'll go to the profile
because we are navigating there and here
we have a first name
and now if you see here we are saying
that we are going to post this form to
say name first name is going to be the
attribute that we are going to trap and
we are going to return profile so the
first name attribute
that we are going to trap here
if we look at the home dot
jsp
okay the user is going to enter a first
name which we will trap as an attribute
so here that value is going to get
trapped we then return the profile jsp
when i go to the profile jsp we are
simply outputting that attribute first
name
so this is my page execution i have just
entered a first name
i'm going to click on the submit button
and it says welcome that particular user
right if i add another user
it actually goes and traps that user id
so again the flow is that in the
controller it's hitting this particular
request map
it then traps the f name
stores that value
into an attribute called first name
and forwards it to the profile page the
profile.jsp is returned by the
controller and simply prints the first
name now we have another page here which
is registered trainee
we are posting
to an ad trainee method
okay we are posting to an ad training
method the command name is trainee
command
and we have here if you look at this we
have actually
included a custom or rather a system
defined tag library which is spring
framework dot org tag slash form so what
we are using here is spring forms rather
than the system defined html5 forms
and here we are
saying s form colon which is the prefix
for this particular namespace that we
have imported on the top
the action is add training and we have a
trainee name we have a marks code we
have a contact number and a submit
button
okay
and now
we are already going and
setting part to com controllers
so in the com controller we've created a
register controller
here you see that we have a request map
for register and a request map for add
trainee and here you see the trainee
command
that is actually getting trapped so the
trainee information will automatically
be passed here and this is the model map
which acts as a scope which allows us to
pass data between the controller and the
view so this trainee object acts like
the model data so if we come to the
com.2 package you actually see the
trainee class which has trainee name
marks code and contact number it has a
parameterized constructor it has an
overwritten two string
constructor and getter and setter that's
all the trainee class actually has
the register controller as we saw has
two maps a register function that
returns
register to any dot jsp
maps to the attribute trainee command
and a add trainee map
that accepts the trainee object along
with the scope the model map which
passes data between the controller and
the view
we are adding attribute training and we
return success okay so if i go to the
success.jsp we are printing the trainee
object
if you look at the register trainee here
you see the command name that we are
trapping and trainee name marks code
contact number which map to the fields
that we have in the model class or the
entity class which is the trainee itself
so now
if we actually look at uh
so let's
close this
come back
we don't add any credentials we click on
login and it says invalid login
credentials
okay so this is
the login that is getting called so you
see here it maps to the login
and here if we do not enter anything it
simply returns invalid login credentials
so this is the login that's actually
getting hit when we click on that button
and if you look at the register trainee
we actually see the input type
over here equal to submit
and the moment
we hit that particular login url it will
simply throw this message saying that
you did not enter the right
credentials
so that is the login screen for us
okay now if i actually add the right
credentials so if i add the correct
credentials here or let's say we enter
the incorrect credentials let's say amit
and password and we say login
it continues to say invalid login
credentials right so in the home.jsp you
actually see the login so this is the
login block which is giving us that
action equal to login username password
and it is displaying dollar of error
message right so the moment i click on
this input button
it looks for a
jsp or rather it looks for a controller
which has a request map so this jsp page
looks for a controller that has a
request map of login
so inside the my controller i have a
request map of login it will go here it
traps the username password checks if
it's not tom and jerry it goes to error
message if it is tom and jerry it
displays profile right and if i look at
error message error message is being
printed in the same page below so in the
home dot jsp we actually are
if you look at the home.jsp page dollar
of error message is being printed and
that's why you get the invalid
credentials out here okay and if it is a
success it will show you the success
page and print
uh that information
okay it will just display
so if you look at the my controller what
we are doing is we are displaying the
profile page here so if i go to the
profile page it will just display the
first name okay so let's try that
so here if i say tom and jerry it should
just display the first name successfully
saying tom so when i log in it says
welcome tom okay the url continues to be
login
now and when i click on this register
link what happens so let's look at the
home jsp again
href equal to register so when i click
on the register link i simply have a
registration which says click here to
register
okay and i already have
a register trainee form
created and this is created using spring
forms as we discussed by creating you
importing the tag library for spring
forms right so that's the registered
training now i have a separate
controller that is managing that so here
is the register so moment i click on
that link it will hit this request map
and it will bring up the register
trainee.jsp
okay and remember we had added the
suffixes here in this particular file so
when i say register training the dot jsp
suffix will already be
automatically be added so let me try
that we'll click on register
and here you see the register trainee
spring form has come up
so we enter the trainee name
we enter the marks code
and we enter the
contact number
right
now if you look at the register trainee
form
this is posting to at trainee so if i go
to the register controller here is where
i have my ad trainee it accepts the
training object as a parameter maps to
training command and the scope which
allows us to pass information between
the controller and the model and here we
are mapping the trainee object and just
returning success.jsp and in success.jsp
we are simply printing the trainee
object
so let's see when i click on submit
query
so let's try the register now
so when we click on register
we'll enter a name for the trainee
we'll enter the marks code and we'll
enter some contact number
and we'll click on submit query and
there you see the trainee object
actually getting displayed
so in the success page we were actually
displaying the trainee object
on the register trainee as we discussed
we were connecting to the add trainee
action
in the register controller we had the ad
trainee action we were passing the
trainee object along with the model
map
and
adding the trainee attribute to the map
and finally returning success and on the
success page we just went ahead and
printed the trainee object
so you saw how the spring mvc pattern
got the request to the dispatcher
servlet it forwarded it to the right
model picked up the model data and fent
and displayed
successfully the required view
which was
the final view that actually got
registered for us
and that is the success dot jsp page
that finally got displayed
let's start with jdbc and spring
hibernate
or jdbc data access object
this is used to build data access layer
of enterprise application
it is a mechanism to connect to the
database and execute sql queries
the database related logic has to be
placed in separate classes called tao
classes
let's do a quick comparison
the difference between
jdbc and spring jdbc based on first
transaction management
jdbc doesn't support
to enable and disable transactions
declaratively well as spring jdbc
supports
distributed transaction management
spring jdbc has support for it
annotation based transaction management
spring jdbc has support
resource allocating logic
in jdbc the connection statement and
prepared statement have to be allocated
explicitly by the developer
spring provides template object and it
extracts the database resource
allocation logic
resource releasing logic in jdbc
developer explicitly writes the logic to
release the database resources
spring provides the jdbc template object
exception handling jdbc throws java
sequel exception there won't be specific
exceptions for specific problems and for
spring jdbc it provides fine-grained
exception handling mechanism to deal
with database
so here we see the dao classes
connecting to the spring jdbc framework
which is an additional layer which then
connects to the jdbc api and finally
talks to the database
what is the advantage of using spring
jdbc api it provides the capability to
establish the connection and interact
with database it simplifies the
development of jdbc hypernate jp and jdo
it provides multiple templates to
interact with database
jdbc template hibernate template jdo
template and jpa template
the terminologies of spring jdbc api
when a connection is opened and closed
when required in an application the
object utilization becomes difficult and
the cost of implementation increases in
such cases connection pooling is used it
is a mechanism of pre-creating a group
of database connections and keeping them
in cache memory for use and reuse it
provides high performance and efficient
resource management
it is an interface that
is an object oriented representation of
connection pooling that's what the java
sql data source does
it is a connection factory for java
application it is an alternative for
driver manager and provides database
connections to the java application its
implementation classes are provided by
the following connection pooling
mechanisms apache basic data source
spring driver manager data source
and c3po combo pole data source
the jdbc template
is used to handle common logic
it is an abstraction of the jdbc
technology the methods provided by jdbc
template are for insert update and
delete methods
the template provides update method
for find my find by balance find by all
row count
available in jdbc spring templates
provides query query for int query
object query for map query for list
to handle batch updates it jdbc template
has convenient methods
here we see some jdbc template methods
the update
for insert update delete
for ddl
for executing query by using prepared
statement for fetching records and
fetching records using row mapper
let's talk about spring jdbc
implementation in an application
to implement we create a database and
table in the database
we then create java projects in eclipse
we then create the spring bean class of
the pojo we then create a tao we then
configure data source and spring bean
spring configuration xml file we then
create spring bean or spring container
either by xml bean factory or
application context
for implementing spring jdbs in an
application we create database and table
in database the syntax to create
databases create database database name
and the syntax to create the table is
create table table name with the
respective columns
next step we create a project in eclipse
then we consider a user class that has
three member variables id name and
salary we then create a dow class where
we create an object of jdbc template we
set it in the constructor then to save
the user to update the user and to
delete the user we actually write string
queries and pass them to the jdbc
template dot update method
to configure data source and spring bean
configuration xml file the jdbc driver
can be used to establish connectivity to
the database during development of basic
unit or integration testing spring has
two data source classes driver manager
data source which returns a new
connection every time a connection is
required and single connection data
source which returns the name same
connection every time a connection is
required
we then configure data source and spring
bin via the xml file so here you see the
bin id
configured to driver manager data source
the property driver class name
configured to the driver the url
configured to the url of the database
the username and password
the id jdbc template configures to the
jdbc empty class and the data source
gets a reference name
then we create a
bean id for injecting the user dow class
and finally we reference the jdbc
template
the last step
create spring container either by xml
bean factory or application context so
here we use the application context we
pass the xml file reference
we get the user down class injected we
then save the user information and print
the status
let's look at a demo where we will
implement the jdbc template using a
combination of jdbc and spring hibernate
so we'll move to eclipse
the first thing we'll do is
we have to add the reference libraries
so we now know that jdbc template is a
design pattern by spring it welcomes the
jdbc orm hibernate also to come in and
assist us from saving our time with
writing lot of config code
so the template design pattern is
actually one of the creational cough
design pattern
the architecture and configuration is
pre-written so we can focus on the
business and persistence logic
so previously jdbc had lots of configs
where we had to create the connection
etc spring now takes care of all of this
and also connection pooling and
exception management as well so jdbc
template helps with this and spring
takes care of the end-to-end jdbc config
so i have created a new project
within that project we have added
comments dot login reference library
and also all of the spring jars along
with the jdbc jar to connector to sql or
mysql database you can add oracle one as
well aspect j and aspect jvivo which we
covered in the last session
so now
let's open up the employee class
it has employee id name age and password
and simple setters and getters
and also a tostring overwrite
that's there in the employee class and
this is the object that we want to save
into the database
we've also created a database in sql
with employee id name agent password and
that is ready
now we have
the mapper class
which is actually creating an object of
employee
and it is mapping
the idh name and password of the
employee
to
the database fields id h name and
password and it's returning the employee
reference
then we have the tao class where we are
defining the data source
the template object and the transaction
manager object because we also want to
learn transactions here and run this as
a transaction
in the set data source we are
initializing the jdbc template we have
an add employee method which takes the
employee object and inserts it using a
parameterized query
into the employee table so we fire the
update method we give the query and the
four parameters of id
name agent password and we return the
count of the records that have been
updated
we have another method that gets all the
employees it returns a list of employees
we say select staff from employee
and we simply pass the query
the sql statement and the mapper class
so that it maps the
values that are there in our employee
object to the database fields and we
return the list employee
here we are just giving a suppress
warning message so that it allows a cast
from
the return of the query method to a list
of type employee
then we are getting all employees based
on the age so we pass the age we write a
parameterized query select star from
employee where age is equal to question
mark again we suppress the error that is
returned and we return the list of
employee
then we have a multi-action method which
takes the employee object
it simply prints performing multiple
actions it defines a transaction scope
and a transaction status as well
we then write the query the first thing
we do is we insert into the employee a
set of values which again are passed
using the update method of jdbc template
and we print the results saying how many
records have been inserted
then we fire another query in the same
transaction scope to get us the employee
which has maximum age
we then fire that statement and we print
the object of type employee which is
returned which has the maximum age and
we commit the transaction so if there is
any error with either of these
statements the entire transaction will
roll back and that what is what we are
doing if there is an exception
these are the setters and getters for
the platform transaction manager and the
template object
we then come to the beans.xml
this is the standard header here we see
we are configuring the jdbc driver
and also configuring the driver manager
data source we give it an id of data
source
we connect to our database which is
called simply do
we provide the username password which
is root we then define the transaction
manager beam to be injected which is of
type data source transaction manager
and we give it a reference of our data
source which is connected to the mysql
database
we then inject the object of the
employee tao class we also give it the
reference of the data source
and we give it the reference of the
transaction manager object that is
injected
so with this
project structure
we are now ready to attempt to use jdbc
template
and connect to the database
create a new record and attempt to see
if it actually works for us
and you see the value here of actually
using jdbc template because jdbc
template takes over the management of
the connection etc rather than we going
ahead and writing the code
so we'll go to the main class
here we have created an object of
application context so we can load the
beans.xml
and we are also getting the
object injected using dependency
injection of spring which is the dow
class object
we then creating a new employee object
with an employee id name
age password
we are calling the add employee method
and passing the employee object and
simply printing this is the list of
records that have been added
and here you see one record has been
added when we executed that
which is the output that we have got let
us check in the database
and you can see the record actually got
added into the database
we will now try to insert
one more record and validate
so let's make it
one zero 4
and we'll change this to s change this
to
d d change the age as well
to 20.
let's execute this once more
and we will check and the second record
has actually now got added
right we did not save this and hence you
saw the same id
so let me run it once more after saving
and
execute and you see the 104 record that
we added has now got
updated in the database
now let us retrieve all the employees
using the second statement that we have
or the function that we have
so here i will uncomment this
so here we are saying get all employees
for employee in the list and simply
print out the employee information
and there you see the employee records
three records that we inserted are
successfully get it printed
let's comment this
and we'll now call the method that we
have that is performing multiple actions
it is also inserting a value in the
database and also getting us the maximum
age
okay
so
before that let me just insert a record
which has the maximum eight so we will
uncomment this
and we will say one zero five
y
and we change the value here
make it 50
save this execute
oops i think i have not commented
successfully
oh yes this is it
save this execute
one record added so that's the record
now with the maximum age of 50.
we'll come down now and we'll execute
the multiple statement method that we
had written
and it's running in a transaction so it
says performing multiple actions one
record inserted and it printed the
employee details 50 which has the
maximum age
right and it would have also updated the
database and executed
that value
so here you see
uh the actual value of using the jdbc
template and how it has actually helped
us
to retrieve relevant data from the
database by outsourcing most of the job
to the jdbc template framework
if getting your learning started is half
the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's move to integrating spring with
hibernate
spring framework provides integration
with hibernate toppling ibatis and jpa
and the reasons to integrate spring with
hibernate in large applications this
integration makes the maintenance very
easy when integrated caching and other
performance tuning is handled
automatically database can be changed
easily without affecting the application
code and integrating hibernate
application with springs avoids creating
the
hibernate.cfg.xml file all information
can be contained in
applicationcontext.xml file
configuring application xml we configure
session factory using class annotation
session factory beam we define hibernate
template by passing session factory and
for the database transaction we define
hibernate transaction manager using the
transaction manager configure aop
hibernate template is a helper class
that simplifies hibernate's data access
code it automatically converts hibernate
exceptions into data access exceptions
by following
awk.springframework.towerexception
hierarchy the structure of hibernate
template class by blick class hibernate
template extends hibernate accessor
implements hibernate operations
so we have multiple methods available
like persist to save the object
save
to persist given object and return the
id save or update to persist or update
given object id to update which updates
the object id to delete the id to get
the object to load the object on the
basis of given id and to return all
persistent objects
let's look at how to create applications
using spring hibernate template we
create a database we create java project
in eclipse we create user java file it
is the persistence class we create user
our java file it is the dowel class that
uses hibernate template we create
application context it contains
information of data source session
factory and then we create test java
file it calls methods of user davo class
here this is how we create the database
we have already discussed how to create
a project we then create the user.java
file and mark it with the entity and id
tag as an annotation
we then create the
user davo file where we create the
hibernate template instead of the jdbc
template and this is how we would
persist the information using the
persist method
finally we create the application
context xml file then we create the
session factory so that we can register
the beam so we are registering the
template by providing the template
reference to the
employee dow bean
and then lastly we create the main way
we load the xml file we pass the bin id
to get the b object and we persist the
information
so let's start with a demo demonstrating
the spring hibernate template so we have
already seen the spring jdbc template we
will now see
the spring hibernate template and the
benefit of using this would be that the
spring container will initialize the
hibernate container for us and spring
will take care of all the things like
creating opening the connection
and configuring the connection and
setting up the
data storage for us etc
so
let's get into eclipse so that we can
set up our demo
we'll start with understanding what are
the jars to be referenced
first of all we'll reference all of the
spring framework jars
in addition we'll reference common
logging
the hibernate jars and the mysql
connector which is the jdbc driver to
connect to the mysql database
now we'll start with
the trainee class which is going to play
the role of
the entity class or the tao class to be
saved
so we are going to mark it as entity at
the rate table annotation so this
remains the same from the previous demo
at the rate id since this is a primary
key and we want to auto generate the
primary key as an identity column so
hence we have set generation type as
auto we have the trainee id trainee name
marks code and contact number we have
the default constructor the getters in
the setters
the tostring has been overwritten and we
have the parameterized constructor it
does not take the id since the id is
automatically getting generated we then
have
the tao class
where we are now defining the hibernate
template object instead of spring
template as we did in the previous demo
we have a getter and a setter that sets
and returns that object
we have a add trainee method that takes
the trainee object it creates
the session by saying hibernate template
dot open session it begins a transaction
it saves the trainee object that is
passed to it
and returns
the id
we then commit the transaction and
return the id out of the function we
also have a function called get all
trainees that returns a list of type
training
here we are defining a new array list
specialized to type trainee we are then
saying
hibernate template dot load all
all the values mapped to this entity
will be loaded here from the database
and we will return that list back
now let's set up the
xml
so here we've just added one more
namespace springframework.org
schema
p for persistence
and of course the rest of it remains the
same
next we see
that we have added the driver manager
jdbc.datasource.driver manager data
source
com.sql.jdbc driver that's the driver
class name the url is localhost and name
of the database is test
username is root password is root
next we create
the session factory
that initializes the hibernate session
bean
we provide
the data source
name data source the references this
particular data source that is the
database connection
the property name is annotated class
com.2.trainee so that's the trainee
class in the com.2 package that is the
annotated class to be initialized
then we set the hibernate properties
this is the sql dialect to communicate
with the database
okay initially we will set this as
create since we want to create the table
show sql true so it generates the sql in
the console then we are creating a bean
with id temp
setting it to hibernate template and
referencing the session factory that we
have created here
post that
we create an id dao we connect it to
and map it to the trainee tao class
since we need to create an instance of
that as well and we reference the
hibernate template out here
so that's all that is there inside the
beans.xml file
now we just need to go and set up the
main program so we'll go to the
main.java
this line remains the case same the
application context is loading the
beans.xml
post that we get the bean name called
tao that's the same name that we have
actually specified here
that maps to the trainee down class
we create a new trainee provide some
values
we call the add trainee function and
provide the method there to the dow
class we then print all the trainees
that are there in the database
so now
you can see when we execute it
we create the table
we insert one value
so here you see
the trainee value when i 12 with the
contact number actually gets returned
with the select all
now let's check in the database as well
select star from trainee
let's select the test database
okay and there you see
this is the record with the id
automatically generated that we had
actually inserted from the back end
so now here
if i need to add another record let me
make this 13
let me change
the value we'll go to the beans class
and
change this from create to update
and save this
right so there are two records now
trainee one and trainee id two that are
returned and let's refresh this and you
see the second record also has got added
with the name ajay so this shows us how
it is pretty easy to set up the jdbc
template
using the hibernate template option
and outsourcing all of the hard work to
spring so spring will take care of
managing all of the connection we don't
we actually did not create a separate
cfg configuration file for hibernate it
was the single beans.xml that actually
did the job for us
let's move to spring jdbc transaction
management section of the jdbc template
integration so here we'll start with
spring jdbc transaction management now
spring provides extensive support for
transaction management this helps
developers to focus on business logic
rather than worrying about integrity of
data in case of systems failure spring
provides an abstract layer on top of
different transaction management apis it
helps application developers to focus on
the business problem without having to
know much about the underlying
transaction management apis
the concept of transactions can be
described using the following four key
properties known as asset atomicity that
requires each transaction to be all or
nothing if one part of the transaction
fails and the entire transaction fails
the database is left in a unchanged
state
consistency property ensures that every
transaction will bring the database from
one valid state to another
isolation ensures the concurrent
execution of transactions result in a
system state that would be obtained if
transactions were executed clearly that
is one after the other
durability property ensures that once a
transaction has been committed it will
remain so even in the event of power
loss crashes or errors
platform transaction manager is a
general interface of all spring
transaction managers
spring has several built-in
implementations of the interface that
can be used with different transaction
management apis like data source
transaction management hibernate
transaction manager and jpa
transactional manager
methods of platform transaction manager
we first have the transaction status
this method returns a currently active
transaction or creates a one according
to specified propagation behavior we
have commit that commits the transaction
and rollback that ruled backs the
transaction which we saw as part of the
demo
here we have the transaction definition
which is the core interface of the
transaction support in spring and it is
defined as follows
we have get propagation behavior method
which spring offers all of the
transaction properties and propagation
offered by ejbcmd get isolation level
that returns the degree to which the
transaction is isolated from work of
other transactions get name which
returns the name of the transaction get
timeout that returns the time in seconds
which the transaction must complete and
is read only this method queries whether
the transaction is read only
transaction status interface provides a
simple way for transactional code to
control transaction execution and query
transaction status
we have the have same point method that
returns whether this transaction
internally carries a save point is
completed the method returns whether the
transaction is completed whether it is
already committed or rolled back is new
transaction the method returns true in
case the present transaction is new
rollback only the method returns whether
the transaction has been marked as
rollback only set rollback only the
method sets the transaction as rollback
only spring supports two types of
transaction management programmatic and
declarative
in programmatic it manages transaction
with help of programming it uses
programming transaction manager directly
to implement the programmatic approach
to implement transactions and to create
instance of transaction definition with
appropriate transaction attributes once
the transaction definition is created
you are calling get transaction method
which returns an instance of transaction
status
the transaction station status object
helps in tracking the current status of
the transaction and programmatic
transaction management uses the commit
method
of platform transaction manager to
commit the transaction
then we have the declarative transaction
management which separates transaction
management from the business code
it allows you to manage the transaction
with the help of configuration instead
of hard coding it in your source
it uses annotations or xml based
configurations to manage the
transactions and it uses tx advice tag
and this creates a transaction handling
advice and defines a point cut that
matches all methods needed for the
transaction at the same time
let's introduce ourselves to spring aop
or aspect-oriented programming
aop is used in applications that have
cross-cutting concerns that is pieces of
logic of code that are written in
multiple classes layers as per the
requirement
some common examples are transaction
management logging exception handling
security aspects and instrumentation
let's understand the concept of concern
a concern is a piece of code that
performs a specific task and there are
two types
core concerns are codes used for
business logic
cross concerns are functions that are
conceptually separate from the
application's business logic but affect
the entire service layer example logging
auditing declarative transactions
security and caching
aspect-oriented programming provides one
way to dynamically decouple core
concerns from cross-cutting concern aop
is one of the basic component of spring
framework and the main idea of afp is to
isolate the cross-cutting concerns from
the application code thereby mortalizing
them as a different entity
services layer deals with two type of
concerns core concerns and cross-cutting
concerns
spring aop provides declarative
enterprise services such as declarative
transaction management it allows users
to implement custom aspects spring aop
is used to track user activity in large
business applications it uses proxy as a
mechanism to implement cross-cutting
concerns in a non-intrusive way
let's look at some aop terminologies
what is an aspect it is a feature of
functionality that cross cuts over
objects
it has a set of api application
programming interface that provides
cross cutting requirements
join point it defines the various
execution points where an aspect can be
applied
point cut tells us about the join points
where access will be applied
advice provides concrete code
implementation for the aspect and target
is a business object that comprises of
aspect businesses or concern
weaving represents a mechanism of
associating cross-cutting concern to
core concern dynamically proxy is an
object produced through weaving there
are two types static and dynamic in
static proxy static method is used to
develop and maintain proxy classes for
each business method in dynamic proxy
proxy is developed at runtime
weaver is code that produces proxies the
proxy design pattern is an actual
business object where it is wrapped into
an another unknown object known as proxy
and substitutes that object in place of
the actual object we will discuss join
point point cut and proxy in this lesson
point cut defines where exactly the
advice has to be applied in various join
points generally it acts as a filter for
the application of various advises into
the real implementation
spring defines two types of point cut
static where it verifies whether the
join point has to be advised or not it
does this once the result is cached and
reused and dynamic where it verifies
every time as it has to decide the joint
point based on the argument passed to
method call
so you see the point cut
and the dynamic method matcher point cut
and finally the control flow point cut
so this is the structure and types that
exist in terms of static and dynamic
point cut
let's talk about the static method
matcher point cut which has two types of
point cuts
name match method pointcut it interrupts
a method via pointcut in advisor
and abstractregex method pointcut
besides matching method by name it can
match the method's name by using regular
expression this pointcut is used to
verify join point based on pattern of
the method name instead of new
then we have jdk regex method pointcut
it is represented by
org.springframework.aop.jdkregexpress
method pointcut
and pearlregex method pointcut it is
represented by
org.springframework.aop.support
dot pearl5 rejects method pointcut
the dynamic method pointcut
this point cut is used to verify the
context from which business method call
is made if method call is made in
specific flow it will be advised
otherwise it won't
pointcut is an interface it is
represented by
point
oc.springframework.aop.pointcut
and the glet class filter method returns
a class filter object which determines
whether the class object argument passed
to the matches method should be
considered for giving advices
a join point is a candidate point in the
program execution of the application
where an aspect can be plugged in this
point could be a method being called an
exception being thrown or even a field
being modified
these are the points where your aspect
code can be inserted into the normal
flow of your application to add new
behavior
a point cut defines the join points
where associated advice should be
applied
so in terms of the join point methods we
have accessible object with a method get
static part which returns accessible
object
and this returns the static part of join
point get this returns the object that
holds the current join point static part
and we have proceed to the next
interceptor
in the chain
how does aop work
the proxy interrupts the call made by
caller to original object it will have
chances to decide whether and when to
pass on the call to the original object
in the meantime any additional code can
be executed spring uses the dynamic
proxy approach where the caller calls to
the business on the original object
a dynamic proxy class is a class that
implements a list of interfaces
specified at runtime so that a method
invocation through one of the interfaces
on an instance of the class will be
encoded and dispatched to another object
through a uniform interface
in the proxy pattern
a class represents the functionality of
another class this type of design
pattern is a structural pattern
it creates an object that has original
object to interface its functionality to
outer word proxy design pattern is used
when we want to provide controlled
access to a functionality it is also
used to save on the amount of memory
used similarly if you want to control
access to an object the pattern becomes
useful
let's look at the ways to generate
dynamic proxy the jdk approach when the
business class implements interface jdk
creates proxy for the business object
the cglib approach the cglib.jar is used
when a business class fails to implement
any interface and jdk is unable to
create the proxy
advice refers to the actual
implementation code for an aspect spring
supports method aspect different type of
aspects available in spring
before advice it executes before a join
point but does not have the ability to
prevent execution flow proceeding to the
join point after advice it is executed
after business method call around advice
it surrounds a join point such as a
method invocation it can perform custom
behavior before and after method
invocation and thrower's advice is
executed if actual method throws
exception
to configure these advices we have to
depend on proxy factory bean this bin is
used to create proxy objects for the
implementation class along with the
advice implementation
the proxy
property called proxy interface contains
the interface name for which the proxy
class has to be generated
the interceptor names property takes a
list of advices to be applied to the
dynamically generated proxy class and
finally the implementation class is
given in the target property
the before advice now this is used to
intercept before the method execution
starts for example a system may need to
perform some logging operation before
allowing users to access resources
so whenever the caller calls the
business method
all before advice code is executed prior
to the business method if an exception
occurs in the method after returning
method will never be called
configuring before advice develop a
business interface in its implemented
class develop a class that implements
after returning advice interface
override its after returning method
cross cutting code is written here the
after returning method is the target
method to be invoked
the object arguments are various
arguments that are passed on to the
method an object target is the target
reference to the object that is calling
the method finally we get a proxy and
make a method call
here is the sequence diagram with the
steps so we have the client which calls
the business method on the proxy which
is the interceptor the proxy
will call the before advise method
control will return back to the proxy
the proxy will then go ahead and call
the actual business method
so if you want to perform some action
before your business method is called
you can write that code in the before
advise function
after advice is used to intercept after
the method execution for example a
system needs to perform some delete
operations after logging out after
advice is executed after the business
method
so the steps for configuring after
advice are as follows we develop a
business interface and its implemented
class we develop a class that implements
after returning advice interface the
override it's after returning method we
cross cutting code is written here
the method is the target method to be
invoked
the object arguments are various
arguments that are passed to the method
and the object target parameter is a
reference to the object that is calling
the method then we get a proxy and make
the method call if an exception occurs
in the method after returning method
will never be called
here you see the sequence diagram we
have the client trying to call the
business method but the proxy intercepts
the proxy goes ahead and calls the
business method
and after
that it calls the after returning and
then the return will come back to the
proxy
around advice it can change the return
argument of the method call it provides
finer control regarding whether the
target method has to be called or not
and it can be performed before business
logic or after business logic how do you
configure a round advice it develops a
class or you rather set up a class that
implements method interceptor interface
you then override its invoke method you
write the crosscutting code you get a
proxy you make a method call and the
parameter of the invoke method is to be
passed
so here you see
you have a client trying to call the
business method the proxy intercepts the
proxy calls
attempts to call the business method and
then immediately calls invoke and then
it calls the business method post that
when an exception happens during the
execution of a method throws advice can
be used through the means of oct or
spring framework to top the throws
advice is used to handle exceptions this
advice is executed only when the
exception is raised the advice has to
implement offspringreamwork.aop
the throws advice
it is just a
marker interface
exception handling code is considered
crosscutting code and can be done for
entire service layer inflows advice with
different kinds of exception parameters
to configure throws advice we develop a
business interface in its implemented
class we develop a class that implements
throws advice interface we then override
its throwing method cross-cutting code
is written here
we then get a proxy we make a method
call and then the throws advice can take
any of the following forms
public void after throwing or public
void after throwing and the method the
object arguments the target and the
exception if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's look at configuring eop in java
applications using the aspect j approach
now there are two ways to use spring aop
aspect implementation you either create
it with annotation or with xml
configuration
we'll need to download the aspect viewer
jar file to get this function in our
application here are the steps
for annotation with aspect j aop we have
at the read before annotation applied
before calling actual method
at the rate after applied after calling
actual method at the rate around applied
before and after the calling method at
the rate after returning applied after
calling actual method and before
returning result after throwing applied
if actual methods throws exception at
the rate point cut is used to define
your point cut
and
if you give
in its various forms it can be applied
on all public methods or on all public
methods of operation class or on all the
methods of operation class etc
and at the rate aspect declares the
class as aspect
let's look at at the rate before
so we there are two classes here perform
and track performance classes so here is
perform and here is tracker performance
assume that perform class contains
actual business methods
the aspect j before advise is applied
before the actual business logic method
using at the rate before advice so here
you see at the rate before at the rate
point cut with the operation and at the
rate aspect so this is the tracker class
which is going to track the
performance class
so you see the output it says calling
message before advice called it triggers
this
then the message method then it calls
the method then before advise again
the second method invoked and then
before n wise again
method invoked
then we have the at the rate after
annotation which is
where we use the same person class and
track performance person class is the
same but accurate after annotation in
the track performance class is used in
this case so the aspect and the point
cut remain the same only at the rate
before is replaced with at the rate
after
and you can see the difference instead
of the befores now you have the afters
getting triggered which is after the
methods individually are called and you
can execute that method to take
appropriate action after your business
methods have executed
you see the around now getting replaced
here instead of the before and after
and the code rather
pretty much the same
and now if you look you have a
additional concern before
additional concern after
again for the second method of before
and the after and that is the
impact of the at the rate around
annotation
xml configuration based aop it uses the
following xml elements to define advice
aop before it is applied before calling
the actual business logic method
after is applied after calling it after
returning is applied after calling the
actual business logic method it can be
used to intercept the return value a
round is applied before and after
calling the business logic method and
after throwing is applied if the actual
business logic method throws an
exception
so here you see the application context
file you see both the beans with ids the
class operation and track operation
the point cuts have been defined
with the expression
and here if i need a before or an after
so here you see the before and if you
need an after this is the code that you
will go ahead and specify
so let's look at advice versus adverse's
aspect j in advice the spring eop is
best used for application specific tasks
such as security logging transactions
this is a proxy based eop you can use
method execution point cut only there
can be little run time overhead it needs
ring ja files only aspect j contains
friendly design patterns
this supports all point cuts there is
less run time overhead than that of
spring aop and you can you need extra
build processes with aspect j compiler
or have to set up ltw or load time
viewing
we'll now start with a demo
on spring aop and we'll go through both
the classical approach by the advice
classes and the aspect j approach
so aop or aspect-oriented programming as
we discussed speaks of aspects or events
or advices
for example before a method is executed
what advice is to be given or after a
method is executed if you want some type
of action to be performed
now aop is constructed on the proxy
design pattern
and the proxy pattern is actually a call
which is made to a actual server via a
proxy server
so the concept here is that the proxy
interrupts this call takes up the call
and as if
it is the real server and then forwards
it to the actual server this can be
useful for auditing purpose
where you want to create an event log or
a logger where you want to track every
action that is performed in your
application
and there are two approaches in aop the
classical approach where we have to
write advice is in a separate class and
it takes a lot of
bean config to write in the xml file or
the modular aspect4j
option which is
via annotations where one central class
can handle aspects of any other classes
all methods that start with is for
example is valid etc
is where you want to perform a check
when all typical methods are executed or
if you want to track your application
this concept can be used again using
aspect 4g you can also use rejects
expressions with modular approaches to
get this done in a very simple way
without having to do too much of
configuration so first we will look at
the classical approach
now i have a simple java project here
that is named as classical as you can
see
there are couple of jar files
that we have reference
the first jar file that we will need is
the commons
logging jar that we had already
downloaded in the previous
example and we can just google for it
and download it
then we need all of the spring aop
jar files or rather the spring jar files
so the spring framework that we had
downloaded in the previous demo we have
just added all of those files here
and we will also need aspect j
for the implementing aspect jaop and
aspect jvweaver both these files also we
can just google for them and download it
so these are the external libraries that
have been added or the external jars
that have been added to the project
then
we created a new package and we called
it com.2
and we created a simple business object
or entity class here called sum bo
inside it we have written a validate
method that simply prints validation
stuff from bio
and we have
overloaded that method with another
method called validate which takes the
age parameter if the age is less than 18
it throws an arithmetic exception that
says not valid age else it prints a
simple message that says
vote
confirmed
we will now learn how to build aspects
and advices around it
so
there is another package that i have
added which is called
com.apps
in this package
a new class
i have added called after advisor now
this is the code that will execute after
the function validate is called and any
appropriate action has to be taken
so here you see after advisor which has
to implement from the interface after
returning advice
we provide the implementation for the
after returning method which takes three
arguments
and here we say some stuff post method
call and argument dot get name
okay that is the code that exists in the
after advisor
now i have added one more class called
the before advisor
now in the before advisor it implements
an interface called method before advice
and provides an implementation for a
method called before
here we just log a message saying
logging before call of method
argument.getname
then i have added a third class called
both advisor
so both advisor will trigger a call as
we saw in the slides before and after
the execution of the method
so here we simply print before method
we then call the proceed so it proceeds
to the next step and then after method
so it will execute the validate method
in the business object and then it will
proceed to call the after method
finally in case there is an exception we
have an exception advisor that
implements throws advice and provides a
method after throwing
here we just print a message which says
additional concern if exception occurs
now we need the configuration file so i
have added a new xml file this file
could have any name like in the previous
demo it's called beans.xml
okay we have added
all the references that are actually
required on the top so this is the
standard header
here is the first bean that is getting
configured so this is id equal to bo
this is a custom name that we have given
for
our sumbio class
then we have said ba
which is a id that stands for the before
advisor class
a a stands for after advisor bh is an id
for both advisor and ea for the
exception advisor
then we have added
a inbuilt class which is awk
awk.springframework.aop.framework.proxy
pattern
and here we have said name equal to
target reference equal to bo
that means all these advices will be
targeting this particular class object
and methods
then we have a list of values that we
would want to populate according to the
advisor that we want configured
finally we add a new package called
com.exe within which we add a class
called main.java
in this class we use the spring
framework
to generate the object on
it into our main method which is
sum bo dot class so we get the beam and
we pass a reference to that proxy id
that we had given and we call the
validate method
then we also have a
over overloaded validate method that
takes an int parameter we put it in a
try catch block because that throws an
exception
now if you look at the bean config file
it is config to aa which means the after
advisor code is expected to execute
so let's go to the main
and we'll execute this
and we will see validation stuff from bo
which is the validate method and some
stuff post call has been executed so
this is the
after advice that is got executed which
is
some auditing
work or tracking work that you want to
perform
after the function is called you can see
that the after advice automatically
executes
now let us modify this
and let us change this to 19
and save it
once we execute this
you will see
that it now calls some stuff
post method called then it actually
calls the second method vote confirmed
and it again says some
stuff post method call
so that is the after advisor executing
after each method call
now let's go to the beans.xml file
and we change this value
to ba which stands for the before
advisor so we'll make this ba and save
this
now when we execute this
you can see it logs the call before the
validate method then it executes the
validate method then again it logs
before call of method validate and vote
confirmed
so this is the code that got executed
twice once before each method
now let's go back to the beans.xml
and we'll configure this as bh which is
the both advisor or the around advisor
let's go to the main
and execute this
and here you see before and after method
functions are called where you can take
appropriate audit action or if you want
to log something you can log it as well
if we change this back to 17
it will generate the exception
and you see here before method
after method it only executed the before
method the exception was raised so the
method did not complete and hence the
after method is not called
now you can also add
multiple
aspects
so let's say i add another one called ea
and i save
we again run
and here you see before validation stuff
after before
additional concern if exception occurs
and
so this is the
println that ran
from the exception advisor class saying
that if the exception occurs
then you also have an exception
which will run
we will now see the aspect j approach
which is
very similar to
this approach but with much better
options where you do not have to do too
much of configuration and you can
actually get everything done just by
annotation
i'll open this project that i have
called aspect approach
let's go and look at the jars that have
been added again i have all the spring
aop or the spring framework jars that
have been added
besides that i have the comments
the aspect j and aspect viewer jars
which have been downloaded from the web
so these are the reference libraries
which have been added
post this
we created a new package
called com.businessobject
within it
we created a business object class
very similar to the previous example
here we have a validate method and we've
over it in another
or rather overloaded another validate
method that simply checks for the age
and throws an exception or prints a
message
we added one more class to this project
which is central aop aspect now this is
the class that is actually doing
all of the
validations or rather all of the
logging before after both around so all
the options are now there in a single
class rather than configuring everything
in the beans.xml
so let's look at what's there here
we have imported the relevant packages
from aspect j
we then put the annotation at the rate
aspect because this is the aspect class
we provide the point cut annotation
where we are targeting the execution of
a method that starts with the word valid
and is there as part of the sumbio class
so we have a method called validate so
this is going to track and map to that
method and the asterisk here indicates
anything that comes after
the word valid which is in our case our
method name is validate and the dots
indicate that it can take no arguments
or any arguments so we have two methods
one called validate which takes no
arguments and another one which is
overloaded that takes the integer
argument
here we have
a function v that now stands for the
validate function so when the validate
function gets called this will execute
then
we have a before
as you see here so this is the before
annotation and this is the method that
will get called before validate here is
the after annotation so this is the
method that will get called
after the
validate these method names could be
anything as long as it takes a value of
or passes an object or accepts an object
of join point and maps to this
synonym tag
over here
then the around
which prints
before and after calling the
actual method
and proceed and then we return that
object and this is the after throwing
for the exception any exception that is
thrown from this class
we print additional concern the method
signature the exception and the end of
after throwing advice
so you see the code is all now
structured into a single class as
against
four different classes that we had to
create
with the previous approach so hence this
is much more simplified
and much more easier and logical to
write as compared to the previous demo
let's go to the beans.xml and you'll see
the header remains common here we
configure the sumbio object here we
configure the
central
aop aspect class so that is the class
that we had created
and this is the
bean
awk dot spring framework dot aop dot
aspect j annotation annotation aware
aspect j auto proxy creator so this is
the class that we need to map to get
this functionality working
now
let's go to the
aspect class
and
here we'll just have
the before and after functional
so we'll commend this
so we just have the before
right or probably i let me comment this
as well
let me come to the main
and we'll attempt to execute this
so here you see before method validate
and before method validate int and it
throws the exception then
now let's come back
to the
central aspect class
we'll also uncomment the after
and run this
and there you see we have the before and
after for the validation again the
before and after for the int and then it
throws the exception
now let's comment this bit
we'll uncomment this bit
and
we'll try the around annotation
and let's come to the main class
and execute this
and now you see the additional concern
before additional concern after
additional concern before the after did
not execute because it was an
exception
let's come back here
we'll commend this
and uncomment the after throwing
and now execute the main method
now here you see the additional concern
the method signature the exception and
the end of after throwing advice and
that is exactly what this particular
annotation was managing
if we get rid of all the
comments
it will execute the entire block
so we'll come to main
and execute
and there you see now all of the aspects
triggering that we have
added
and if we correct this
to 19 we will not have the exception
thrown
so here you see
additional concerned after calling after
method
so that shows us how easy it is to use
aop to actually configure our
application to write before and after
join points that will execute and
advises that will execute before and
after our functions are called so that
we can do some important initialization
cleanup or also logging activity from an
audit trail perspective
the key takeaways from this session have
been that spring mvc is used to develop
web applications that uses mpc design
pattern spring mvc is used to make web
application development faster cost
effective and flexible dispatcher
servlet handler mapping controller model
and view and view resolver are the
components of spring mvc the key
takeaways from this session have been
that spring jdbc is used to build data
access layer of enterprise application
it is a mechanism to connect to the
database and execute sql queries the
database related logic has to be placed
in separate classes called our classes
connection pooling is a mechanism of
pre-creating a group of database
connections and keeping them in cache
memory for use and reuse it provides
high performance and efficient resource
management and spring supports two types
of transaction management programmatic
and declarative so the key takeaways
from this session has been that aop is
used in applications that have
cross-cutting concerns where a piece of
logic or code that is written in
multiple classes and layers as per the
requirements
spring defines two type of point cut
static where it verifies whether the
join point has to be advised or not it
does this once the result is cached and
reused
dynamic it verifies every time as it has
to decide the join point based on the
argument passed to the method call
spring uses the dynamic proxy approach a
dynamic proxy class is a class that
implements a list of interfaces
specified at runtime so that a method
invocation through one of the interfaces
on an instance of the class will be
encoded and dispatched to another object
through a uniform interface
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on spring mvc in depth
tutorial if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you need the
resources that we have used in this
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you